je m'appelle bardot je suis addict au
challenge mais là je vous parle d' une
véritable addiction
parce que vernon qui me fait peur je
parle en public
du coup quand on m'a proposé de faire un
thé xx et d'orge accepte donc du coup
pour ajouter un peu de contexte à tout
ça j'ai grandi avec l'explosion
d'internet et c'est ce genre de slogans
qui est venu accompagner son
développement
quand on part de là tout devient
possible
et j'utilise le jeu pour avoir l'audace
d'aller chercher ces challenge et me
permettre de les réaliser le jeu amène
la performance et le bonheur et je vais
vous prouver en vous montrant comment
j'ai transformé en jeu alors voici mon
calendrier d'avant d'étiage 7e jézabel
des big boss c'est ispos c'est les
épreuves donc dans les jeux vidéo qui
permet de déverrouiller le niveau
suivant
j'ai aussi des points ressources et les
gars donc en janvier
j'ai quitté mon job c'était pas évident
nous sommes aujourd'hui sur riposte de
la prise en parle en public vous êtes
mon challenge est en mai je vais créer
mon entreprise
du coup je cherche un associé j'en
profite pour passer le message et j'ai
j'ai épinglé sur un tableau les profils
des informations des compétences que
j'ai relié à des fils je me crois
vraiment dans ncis et surtout je
m'arrête pas là je m'arrête pas à la
gamification donc du milieu
professionnel
je l'utilisé aussi dans ma vie
quotidienne
c'est à dire qu'il ya quelque chose que
je déteste le plus au monde c'est le
ménage et du coup et non je me déguise
pour les ménages et donc du coup la
preuve pour vous la preuve
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors je me suis un peu mouillé la vos
goûts mais est ce que je veux dire par
là c'est que poser une couche de plaisir
à la réalité
c'est donc l'essence même de la
vinification la qualification elle vient
du new game le jeu anglais c'est l'art
d'utiliser les mécaniques du jeu dans un
autre contexte pour les en optimiser et
aujourd'hui j'aimerais vous prouver
qu'on peut utiliser ces média mix au
travail pour plus de bien les pour les
employés et plus de performance pour
l'entreprise
alors si je reviens à mon cas quand je
travaille je peux pas m'empêcher de me
demander pourquoi je fais les choses
comment je pouvais les faire mieux et
avec plus de plaisir
je suis donc bel et bien un des fruits
de la génération y la génération du
pourquoi une génération qui est
exigeante et infidèle à l'entreprise
c'est une génération qui a besoin de
sens au quotidien mais est ce que vous
croyez vraiment qu'ils y sont les seuls
à avoir besoin de sens en fait ces
chiffres la montre que la société et les
tendances ont changé on est tous
réceptifs aux jeux et loisirs pour une
place beaucoup plus importante dans nos
vies si on a tous besoin de sens donc
vous êtes tous concernés
donc il est bon de se demander pourquoi
l'homme at-il cette prédisposition beau
jeu en quoi je sais pas si on joue
encore dick roche
mais en quoi empiler des bonbons dans
quand dick roche est plus stimulant voir
addictif je fais de la saisie comptable
parce que finalement on est sur la même
profondeur de travail
sauf que chez gandi crush on a des
visées les actions et le feedback pour
provoquer un évanouissement émotionnel
et du coup il y a une véritable
influence sur le cerveau
en fait le jeu va générer la création d
or mode de dopamine et de sérotonine et
ce sont les hormones que du bonheur
du coup le jeu nous fait sentir cette
sensation de bien-être d'une tonne en
vie et nous motive
vu qu'on est sur le territoire si je
cite le calme parce que activer la
motivation humaine c'est le facteur le
plus puissant mais aussi le jeu complexe
il existe deux types de motivation la
motivation qui évite intrinsèque qui vit
à la tâche la mission le tueur de la
notion même et à la motivation qui dit
extrinsèque donc liés à l'environnement
c'est l'ambiance au travail c'est le
salaire c'est le goût du café et du coup
on fait souvent les managers ils se
trompent en essayant de stimuler le
mauvais endroit vinification motivation
du coût de ce fait on enfin pour exemple
on ne peut pas motivé en fait sur sur
tâche avec en redonnant une prime aux
salaires voilà du coup je vais vous
donner deux exemples de gamification au
travail sur ces deux types de motivation
alors vous êtes tous déjà fait appeler
par deco senteurs pour des enquêtes et
je suis sûr que vous avez pour la
plupart parfois pas été très aimable moi
je vous propose l'envers du décor parce
qu'il ya un réel quand juste de
motivation sur ses métiers et en fait
l'histoire c'est l'histoire d'une agence
de téléprospection qui a donc mis son
client à peau de sherlock à ce jouet
explique ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'elle avait un réel enjeu de
motivation et de formation sur un temps
encore pour les salariés formés sur des
questions techniques
ce que le directeur d'une agence à fait
il a acheté un buzzer il a imprimé des
questions question pas si on va sur des
pistes à john questions pour un champion
est en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est que
les employés c'est
motivés eux mêmes sont pris au jeu et
clou du spectacle le client a voulu
venir vérifier la qualité des questions
des questions et des réponses apprises
et bien non seulement il a accepté de
jouer le rôle de julien lepers
mais c'est carrément pris au jeu alors
jetez les cartes du coup l'objectif de
performance a été atteint l'entreprise a
gagné l'appel d'offres et surtout tout
le monde a pris beaucoup de plaisir
donc ça c'était comment motiver par
rapport à la tâche le coeur de la nation
je vous donne un exemple sur
l'environnement comment faire + 5% de
marge en doublant la tendance des années
précédentes
c'est le challenge qu'un grand groupe
agroalimentaire a relevé à l'ag il y
avait la convention annuelle qui était
donc une semaine normalement en france
qui devait utiliser à rio pour toute
l'équipe est en fait ce qui fait passer
ici c'est que ça a été trois années les
métiers ça au petit n'est plus leur
formation et optimiser l'organisation
on est passé d'un jeu et d'objectifs
individuels à l'équipe et à l'entreprise
et du coup ils sont tous salariés
en fait en stimulant sentiment
d'appartenance le jeu il nous rend plus
performant on est toujours sur eux sur
les belles mécaniques
on va poser un décor des règles du jeu
une situation d'échec et situation de
victoires et qui est vraiment important
là dedans c'est de redonner du sens avec
l'histoire qu'elle soit fictive avec
questions pour un champion ou non on
replace l'objectif commun on va rendre
visible pour faire adhérer et anvers en
belgique pour participer est en fait le
simple plaisir de jouer ça va créer une
émulation collective et ça anatole
rapport qui était aussi en stratégie de
jeu l'a prouvé mathématiquement les
stratégies gagnantes sont les stratégies
collectives et collaborative quelque
chose est vraiment très important par
rapport à tout ça c'est la récompense
la récompense
en fait j'avais alors pas su de la
récompense elle sera toujours supérieur
à la valeur viennent pour l'entreprise
acheter un buzzer du scénario c'est
complètement rentable si on atteint les
objectifs
mais il ya une réelle valorisation
humaine qui est important ce final mais
en fait c'est ça que je viens faire le
jeu il va venir répondre aux besoins que
tout humain a dans sa vie et dans son
travail qui sont les besoins d'identité
comment je pensais avoir un structure et
quel sens à ce que je fais les besoins
de reconnaissance les besoins
d'épanouissement et en répondant donc à
tous ses besoins à la fois le jeu
devient le saint graal de la motivation
au travail
alors du coup vous allez me demander
pourquoi ce n'est pas encore en place
maintenant quand je parle de
gamification en général on dit les
margaux ça a l'air génial mais pour moi
impossible de l'imposer d'un visa de le
faire pire
pourquoi parce qu'on va juste venir
bousculer les habitudes et c'est
vraiment ce qu'est dior
il ya aussi un problème à venir venir
toucher la barre psychologique de venir
toucher le devenir france ce soulier
elle est sacrée du travail avec la chute
et du jeu finalement c'est simplement la
peur du changement mais on peut vraiment
à rester sérieux au travail tout en jour
alors une bonne gamification au travail
ce qui n'est pas un jeu d'enfant parce
qu'ils ne savent vraiment être pris
comme un outil de mauvaise compétition
du coup pour son adoption il va falloir
une excellente communication
il va falloir de la bienveillance et la
justice les problèmes d'ego et les
délits pour la vienne elles doivent être
punis even redonner du sens et du
plaisir au travail
c'est maintenant que ça se passe alors
regardez des équipes motivées sa relève
vraiment un challenge pour les
entreprises la qualification est en
train d'arriver dans les entreprises les
demain le bien-être il sera vraiment
pris
sérieux il ne sera plus comme il sera
vraiment vu comme un facteur de
productivité
demain nous on devra tous bosser dans
des boîtes à la google
demain les comptables ils auront des
points et des couleurs sur leur bilan
jauron à contacter roche demain on
donnera des vies sous forme de coeur aux
opérateurs machine pour les sensibiliser
aux accidents du travail mais déjà vous
vous pouvez être proactifs en trois
points premièrement ce qu'on appelle en
marketing le storytelling redonner du
sens avec l'histoire
vous produisez pas d'illusions mais vous
contribuez à la création de cendres
renault sport deuxième point
ayez de l'audace et y ait l'audace de
proposer votre idée et dit croire dans
la boîte je travaille encore aujourd'hui
on a mis en place en fait un écran sur
lequel satish chaque nouveau client
du coup on replace le client au centre
et à chaque nouveau pion donc si tu as
vu sur un écran via un gyrophare qui
s'allume et la musique de mario qui
retentit dans clio vous savez ce que ça
fait et ben en fait combien
et aucun ce taper dans les mains et
c'est vraiment là où je veux en venir
c'est à dire que adopté le ton que vous
voulez vous n'êtes pas oublier
d'utiliser la musique de mario mais
taper dans les mains rebooster l'esprit
d'équipé parce que finalement c'est
l'humain qui fait l'entreprise et
surtout ne vous arrêtez pas là donc je
vous ai donné un des exemples mais créer
vos propres outils de gamification pour
embellir votre vie pour en faire même
une philosophie et surtout prenez du
plaisir dans tout ce qu une fesse je
vous souhaite un google
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]